luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start hey
guys and welcome back to the leia heil pun
show it is of course powered by icon plus capital
the vc firm definitely check them out on socials
they are absolutely brilliant ben great to have
you welcome to the show how are you doing today
really great to be here um it's it's great
just uh arrived in the office uh had had a
bit of a travel but it's uh really great
to have this this conversation with you
yeah you've just flown in from miami which is
insane and we're gonna get um all the information
on your um i don't know whether to call it secret
meetings it wasn't that secret um with the mayor
um but before we jump in just wanna let everybody
know that this is sponsored by block fi so block
fi you can actually get i think it's around six
percent interest on a couple different stable
coins on there um you can get 250 when you
sign up so definitely would recommend them um
but anyway ben welcome back you're in romania
right now yeah definitely uh just just arrived
uh had some conversations with the team
and um excited for this conversation
yeah it's gonna be great um we were trying earlier
and i think your community is so vibrant what
you've managed to build um everybody is so excited
for this conversation they've submitted a million
and one questions so i really hope that we're able
to get through them all but before we do i do want
to learn a little bit more about you um so how
did you first get into crypto i think that has
to be the most obvious question that everybody
wants to know for sure um i would say and will
always say that the the lron community really
rocks and we would not be here uh without them so
um going a bit into the the questions i
initially stumbled into bitcoin sometime in 2012
i believe um played with stuff and it was 2013
that that i really went deep down the rabbit hole
uh but i always asked um this fundamental
questions i i was very fascinated in intrigued
by technologies that um would essentially have the
potential to change the dynamics of humanity um so
they would be able to be put on the scale of
evolution and uh bitcoin at that point was
extremely intriguing uh it had do two properties
first it looked like a joke uh a lot of people
like the serious people would not uh look
at at bitcoin would not understand it
and then it looked extremely fascinating
because it was the first combination of
economics and technology in a way that we've
never seen before now as as i studied things
it became clear that um one bitcoin had this very
um fascinating trajectory for for the future and
what what it could achieve but it also had some
limitation um as as i saw them then um after that
i i basically joined the nem core team after that
i i started the fun to to fund some some projects
that i thought would solve some of the most
pressing problems in the space and then um after
seeing that some problems were not getting solved
at all uh we essentially gathered the team uh with
which we can literally build rockets and started
working on lron so um here's where we are now
so for those that don't know how
would you describe elrond in just
one sentence um with elrond our goal is to build
the backbone for a high bandwidth low latency
transparent financial system and secondly give
access to this new financial system to anyone
anywhere in the world okay so a lot of people
say that you guys are similar or competitors to
ethereum and cardano do you agree and if so how
are you different and how are you better that's
the most important question obviously yeah i would
push back a bit on on this type of comparisons
because i i believe that people uh very easily put
all the projects in some boxes and and maybe for
simplicity they they always do that but the idea
with elrond is that we're trying to underscore
what maybe most of the people in the space forget
that um we're not here to compete with um bitcoin
with ethereum where we're we're not the killer uh
ethereum killer or bitcoin killer but rather we
are focused on bringing the next billion people in
the space because we believe that if we can bring
this large elephant um in the space then uh we
will be the wave that will lift all boats um in
that sense bitcoin will get uh gain tremendously
ethereum will be able to gain tremendously
and even all the all the other projects with which
we we essentially have a lot of collaborations
we'll be able to gain so how we differentiate
specifically is that we've solved the uh
performance problem for the blockchain space such
that any application that really wants to build
and embed blockchain into into their architecture
they can do it uh right now not in the future with
um elrond and then secondly we're putting a lot of
focus into bringing a user experience in the space
that will enable anyone in the world to interact
with this technology without having them to learn
rocket science um so this is the focus and and we
believe that this is a non-zero-sum game um that
is we can collaborate with all these interesting
projects that really bring value in a way that
we gain a lot and build a lot of value
but they also also gain and it's this
where we see the largest opportunity for the
space speaking of adoption um and collaborations
obviously you were in miami and we saw
the picture of you with the mail which
is really really cool so can you tell us what
that meeting was about and what came from it
um sure so i'll give you a an overview
of that we always want to to speak about
some matters when they essentially come out but i
will say this miami is at this point the epicenter
of the world in terms of technology there's an
energy hunger and focus there that you don't
see anywhere in the world and it's absolutely
fascinating to see that you have a mayor like
mayor francis um a lot of really smart uh people
uh technical people founders and and so forth and
people that are super hungry and i cannot
underscore how important this is because they they
don't want to sit around and just have discussions
but they're focused on building something and they
see this large opportunity and then there's also
all this other opportunities with super launch
large funds um other startups and and so forth
so this is one of the things that we've um seen
before it was super obvious this is why in january
i i already was one time to miami to have a
conversation with mayor francis and i remember
that we were discussing with the team that
there's a particular window in
which some mountains can be moved
you cannot do do this before not do this after and
this is why um we believe that miami will play a
key role in in elrond's future um of course the
maybe to give some ideas um we see that there
will be a lot of startups there right a lot of
blockchain startups we want to be present and
offer them some of the best tools and best support
they really need um this is this is the gist of it
i i will definitely follow up with more info as
we finalize some things and get them done yeah i
mean i i know i get that it's you can't exactly
announce things which have just happened um but
no definitely appreciate that i think you're
you're right miami um the energy there is truly
unbelievable and it's so refreshing to see a
mayor um pushing for that kind of innovation
um i'm london-based right now and um our maya and
the whole of london and the whole of the uk to be
honest in my in the only way that i i can never
think to put it it needs a facelift basically
um and it's so refreshing just to see miami
leading the way um so that's really really
cool now you guys um have the maya the maya am i
am i pronouncing that correctly the maya exchange
yes mark so there are a lot of questions that have
come through um about that so i'm just gonna grab
them here so um okay so some people say that it
looks like the um there's gonna be a delay for
the launch so can you talk to us about that why
is there a delay so the the idea with the meyer
exchange is that um we've put a lot of thought
into bringing a dex a decentralized exchange that
will work on lrand uh bringing it to the market in
a way where this becomes not just another dex but
the key component that everyone will use in the
elrond ecosystem and beyond um of course there's
a tremendous effort to get this done and push
it out it always seems like this is just a small
thing you get a few things done and then you have
it out but it turns out that the mara exchanges
is a monster uh it's uh extremely important that
we have more than seven smart contracts that
interact with a lot of critical information then
we have front-end and we have apis then we have
a lot of microservices that need to interact and
i was just discussing with the team before that
it seems like the days that we invest right now
are almost each day at least one million dollar
that we um essentially um save out of the
people's money with all the hacks that we've seen
in the space it's like do you want to spend the
days uh really focusing getting the security
um super high or do you want to pay this
money after you launch so it's that simple
and and we're super close um i would say that um
we are pushing super hard so that next week uh we
have a launch with the community on the on the uh
test net so that we we can test this together and
and so forth we are super excited about that but
we also want to be very very um aware that this is
an incentive for people to hack everything to hack
the smart contracts to hack the exchange and we
want to be very meticulous in that respect um and
that being said uh the the progress has been uh
tremendous um it always looks a lot simpler when
you when you set out but then you discover it's um
super large uh still as we get very very close uh
i believe that the community will be tremendously
excited about this yeah i mean i think they
already are to be honest because the majority of
the questions that came through were um about the
maya exchange and the wallet um somebody actually
asked if you guys are thinking um of creating a
card and i think that's a great question because
for me personally when i was getting
into the space i found the card
um exchanges which provide a card are
so powerful when it comes to adoption
it just makes it so much easier um you know
because sometimes it can be such a headache
moving um your your crypto from a wallet
onto an exchange then into your bank account
if it's all just in one ecosystem it's such a
smooth experience so is there a card on its way
for sure so uh maybe to differentiate a bit we
have the miner exchange the meyer decks and then
the meyer application the meyer application is
this a very very simple uh perhaps the simplest
ux in the space and also uh the most compelling
and so in this application uh we currently have
eagle we have ethereum we have binance and very
very soon uh bitcoin i saw that some people asked
about this uh in the in the thread you've got
to have bitcoin you just you can't not you know
for sure for sure 100 and it's it's super close
uh i was just discussing this with the team um i i
think it will come uh probably in the next one or
two weeks uh for sure and um the idea is that with
the meyer application we're trying to provide this
very simple and compelling experience to the space
and then within this of course you want onboarding
fiat fiat on rams fiat off-ramps and a card
if you can have this you you basically
have extracted away the entire complexity
and can really push forward uh the fiat on ramp
we have um the fiat off-ramp um it turns out
again this is one thing that as we discussed
with with some of the uh providers initially
it looks super simple and then yeah there's
a mountain of legal discussions that you keep
having uh but still we're we're making progress
and i i think we will have this it just is
essentially just a legal discussion so on weekly
basis we keep having the same discussions on a
legal front and then the card as well um it's just
a a legal part that we have to get through that
we're making uh progress on um and we will have
the card um it just has not come as fast as we we
want it to come everything takes time and i always
say it can take time as long as it's worth it you
know you don't want to rush things and then you
have technical issues and things go wrong you know
i think i think that's actually what charles
hoskinson actually says a lot of the time
when when the cardano community sort of complain
about how long things take but you know you don't
mess up no no no it's uh it's uh i think we have a
lot of momentum we have a really great progress uh
and some of these features are are coming um
they will hopefully come during the next few
months we're pushing and we understand
that the card will be tremendously valuable
for the community so we're pushing as hard as
possible yeah absolutely okay so here's another
really interesting one um so somebody has asked
when um will the us be able to purchase eagle
through the maya wallet uh yeah this is another
great question and we we've been pushing on this
for months now um it turns out that the us uh for
some reason is especially about legal discussions
yeah so uh what whatever the other uh there was a
funny tweet at some point that paul graham put out
and paul graham you you probably know him from
y combinator said something like um there were
several countries or several let's say continents
gathering together and discussing about innovation
the u.s said i'll bring the technology asia said
something else and then europe said i'll bring
the legislation or something the legal part
but interestingly enough it seems like this
is even uh quite the opposite like yeah it
seems like everyone else is building and then
in the u.s 80 percent is legal discussion
and you you get to have a lot of backlog
just because of this legal discussion so the
short version is again we have some partners
we're making progress but there's two two basic
limitations there limitations there one is the
legal part which we keep going through and it's
it's basically almost done and then there's there
seems to be a kind of almost industry bandwidth
limitation at this point especially for the us
where uh most of the projects see much more demand
that they anticip than they anticipated and we're
trying to help them with the integrations and
and stuff like that so us is the largest market
we understand that and we're pushing super hard
to make it happen uh hopefully it comes out soon
yeah everybody that i speak to that's trying to
build or you know even if it's on a personal level
not just like on a company level or whatever it
is um is always trying to break the us market and
it's a nightmare for those who aren't american who
who you know don't have residency or citizenship
or whatever it is it's just a nightmare um i mean
i think it's even a nightmare for americans to be
honest um with the sec i would say oh really
why would you say so like uh just ask yourself
why no company is putting the hq in the us even
the us startups are located somewhere else to uh
not have this type of discussion so it's a bit
crazy on that front yeah no actually i think
absolutely right um but here's another really
interesting interesting one somebody has asked
um would maya ever become a messaging service
like whatsapp or signal or something like that
um yes the the idea for a messaging app is
of course super compelling um and we've had
a lot of discussions around this uh internally of
course what it would mean to to have a super dap
basically the the idea would be that you of
course have money and everything related to
money um but then you you have messaging on the
internet and then you have browsing so if you
could have something like that you basically
have everything that someone needs to do
and there are interesting and successful
applications that have done this if you
look at wechat this is precisely uh what they've
done um it's just that we want to make sure that
we focus on having the first version of elrond
exactly what we need uh the first version of
mayar with some of the key applications and
then move forward to to adding new services
in order to make it still super simple for
the user um but messaging uh is definitely
one of the key applications that we'll
see on the on the uh very near future
i think even 10 years ago it was um there were
rumors that that's what facebook were trying to do
they were trying to be you know the wechat of
the west or whatever it is so it's definitely
something which people are trying to do i always
wondered why they weren't able to achieve that
i guess this may be a lot about ux so in the west
the users are not necessarily used to having one
application with 10 applications inside and then
in china they're used to uh wechat which basically
has everything you can browse the web you can do
messaging you can do payments you can do all the
other stuff so it's much more an element of what
users really want what they would get used to
and making this still a super compelling
applications because it's easy to just put in
stuff and much more difficult to make it still
very usable not adding too much complexity and
and so forth but uh yeah i i would say that
we are going to see a lot of explorations
in this respect we even encourage a lot of people
to to come and build something like this on elrond
and uh yeah with mayar i i guess we'll have some
some interesting experiments on that front as well
and speaking of um adoption globally
um we've got a cool question which is
what is the strategic plan for adoption in africa
asia and then the us which you did touch on
sure elrond is very very strategic in this respect
so we're trying to not just do stuff that everyone
does but rather take some specific elements where
we know we can shine and and beat anyone in the
market where we can move at high speed and then
execute on that so what we are focused on right
now is it's clear that we have a huge advantage
in europe um europe is where the majority of
the community is it's also clear that asia is
super huge as an opportunity but also very very
idiosyncratic so the the the things that would
work in europe do not necessarily work in the
in in asia and then it's the same for the us
the us is a huge market but once you go in
it takes a bit of time to really go in and make
sure that um the the legal part is bulletproof
uh but once you do of course there's a huge
opportunity in the us as well so i would say
that europe is is pushing really fast forward uh
during the next period asia will will follow and
then the us uh as well um it's just that the us
will probably be pending the the legal stuff and
as soon as it is done uh it will just seem like uh
it happens all of a sudden but it was uh years of
work in the background as it usually is that sort
of reminds me of what people say on social media
when they say um people look at you and think it
was overnight success or whatever it is and you're
just there trying to grinding every day to make
it happen yeah just a few years just a few years
yeah not that hard just a few years of blood sweat
and tears basically to break into those markets
um so you you did touch on this um but we'll just
we'll just go to back to a second so how soon will
the decks be released it's a bit more specific
yeah what we are focusing and what we are pushing
on is that um during the the second half of next
week and i'm always mindful of how many things are
popping up and i'll usually discover uh discovered
each day but we're pushing super hard at
end of next week sometime we can go out with
uh the first version on the test net uh we'll
have a really cool um community approach there uh
where we do some some um cool stuff whether it's
testing competitions and and so forth just to
make sure that everything is working properly then
immediately after that uh there will be the the
official launch but uh yeah this this is a huge
huge milestone for for elrond and this is why
we're pushing um as hard as possible to get it out
and can you tell us about some of the um d
fight interactions that will be available on
the maya app um yeah so the meyer dex is sort of
um independent of the meyer app first but what's
super cool about it is that you'll have this um
unique user experience where through the meyer
wallet which is a mobile wallet you'll be able
to interact with the meyer decks very simply to
provide liquidity for different uh farming options
different liquidity pools and then exchange
some tokens of course and at first you'll you'll
basically have three pools so there will be an
an eagle pool a mex pool um and and um essentially
a usd pool all paired with uh mar exchange token
um and um yeah this this this i suppose will
evolve very fast so immediately after we push
this out all the projects that have been
waiting for something like this can list
their tokens so this this will keep a natural
feedback loop uh really fast kickstart but uh
yeah we want to take this out push it out um
of course there's also the maya exchange token
with the native token of the tags um
people are waiting of course for that
to claim their token be able to provide liquidity
um so this this is what we're focusing at this
point uh there's also borrowing and landing that's
coming at a later point and we've discussed about
the the mar land function um and some other tools
um of course but we we take it one step at a time
always one step at a time so we're gonna move
on just a little bit um and someone's asked um
can you elaborate on the partnership with oin and
how be utilized um for the upcoming maya exchange
uh so the idea there is that we will issue um
a token um a stable coin that is eagle-backed
uh so how it will be used is of course will
have a pair that will launch on the meyer
decks and people will be able to exchange the
token take it use it in some other ecosystems uh
but the the meyer exchange can be seen as this
global liquidity pool that we will gradually
where we will gradually put all the tokens
that exist within the lrand ecosystem and um
all the new even nfd elements that that will come
to the ecosystem okay um so in a minute i do want
to go and do a live um ama so i just want to let
everybody to know so if if there are any questions
that you feel haven't been answered yet if
there's anything else you feel you really want
to know please just put them um in the live chat
now um and then i can scroll through and we will
we'll ask all of your questions um but before
we do um the live ama do you have one more
question which is actually really interesting
um somebody asked would you ever look at doing a
collaboration between l runs and apple um because
they are actually looking for a crypto expert and
they say that the maya wallet would be perfect um
for ios no i think everyone is super excited to
see um some of the news that came out uh last week
i guess uh that um apple was looking for someone
on the payment slash cryptocurrency side it's
awesome news uh it's great to finally see them
move forward we would be super happy to to have a
conversation and um help them with that um and um
it's actually a bit surprising that they've
moved so slow uh on that front so they they're
uh they're basically the slowest uh in this
respect uh we have interesting conversations
with some some larger um or not larger
but super large players um that are moving
uh forward trying to experiment and and there's
even one um element that that i i'll briefly
touch on which is we announced a collaboration
with hall ride and audi and then um there was a
lot of excitement in the community when audi
um started showing a bit of more interest uh
with even the social media stuff and and so forth
interacting with the elrond community so um when
you see this type of very large players starting
to make the moves uh you know that everyone else
will start to make a move because this is a bit of
um at first it it's almost like a mexican standoff
and then it becomes an arms race when when the
first state moves in then it's a race who is
going to move in fast how much time do we have
and so forth it's the same for the companies and
i guess during the next few months we will
certainly see some larger players again similar
to tesla similar to to the other interesting
ones making a move hopefully not like tesla
uh but uh yeah yeah i'm still here let me just hit
my camera back on there we go um yeah i mean apple
they have moved really slow but i think what's
really interesting is a lot of people are saying
we're going head first into a bear market but
i just i don't feel that way whatsoever there's
too much bullish sentiment going on um you know
apple talking about their own crypto expert i mean
it feels positive to me yeah i i guess people
always default to this um like to the simplest
narrative they have in the mind so uh what's
what's bearish what's bullish uh what's the cycle
of course we have several cycles is this cycle
over um what if we look historically what's
happening and so forth but i i believe at this
point um it's much more important to understand
the fundamentals and why this could be hugely
different because of course you have a lot of
cycles but we have to understand and get reminded
that the cycles are are based essentially on
fundamentals if you don't have fundamentals then
you're going to have a re-encouraged market yeah
but if you have the fundamentals if you can
accommodate millions and tens of millions and
hundreds of millions of users everything changes
uh at that point the idea of the super cycle
um supersedes um the the normal stuff and um i
do believe that we're at that point of course
this doesn't mean that you'll have you'll not
have volatility you'll not have the normal crazy
stuff that you normal crazy stuff that you you
uh usually have in the space but fundamentals are
changing the game completely yeah and i think
that is what's going to drive in my opinion this
second part of this cycle this potential super
cycle um all right so i'm going to head over to
the comments now so guys if there's anything you
feel hasn't been answered if you have any other
questions please just throw them in the comments
now because i'm going to go through them all and
we're going to actually do a live ama okay so um
a lot of people are asking when coinbase listing
i i'd love to be able to give an answer to that
uh of course we're doing as i said everything
within our power to make sure that uh things are
clear on the legal front that we can help even on
on technical aspects whenever they're needed we
do have conversations with with all the largest
exchanges in the world and all i can say is
that from our end we're we're ready um just yeah
it's just that uh we we need to see them ready
as well i understand what about nfts um on the
hour on blockchain so nfts are already available
on the airborne blockchain we actually introduced
a standard a new standard for nfds something
like the ethereum standards but with with a few
improvements where you have um embedded royalties
and stuff like that that you can configurate
and this is very very cool um we know that there
are several projects that are already building
something on these standards but we are
also taking this proactively and preparing
um a launch in the meyer application with nfds
so i'll probably um have a much more concrete
update as soon as uh the light at the end of
the tunnel is clear um things look awesome um
at this point so we already have the concepts
the design we've went through all of that
but uh we're now pushing super hard to to make it
uh real and get this new feature out for the users
so uh we'll probably be out sometime after the
the meyer decks what about um a digital identity
um digital identity is this feature that will
it's super tricky the the trickiness is not
that you will not solve digital identity it's very
easy to find a solution but the tricky uh part
is how do you get adoption there are one
000 uh digital identity solutions for um
different things on the web no one knows about
them they they don't work because they cannot
scale there is no incentive to to adopt them so
we've been thinking a lot about digital identity
and how you could solve this in a way
where there's an incentive for you to
adopt it let's say you you have something
like the elrond um hero tags which are this
dns uh functions where you have not only eagled
um uh addresses but you have bitcoin addresses
ethereum addresses binance addresses and and
many other tokens uh afterwards if this becomes
super useful or useful enough then the users
will start adopt this as a kind of digital id
uh option but the digital id will be a secondary
feature uh because they will always adopt it just
because it's super useful and then you have this
this is always the tricky part you you can get the
product but if you don't have the distribution
uh you essentially don't have a useful product
and we might have something super
cool on the on the digital id part but
uh we'll we'll push on that when it's ready so
there's somebody absolutely um asking the same
question over and over again in the comments
which i just have to ask you um otherwise i
won't be able to see any of the other comments
so somebody asked who is ben's biggest idol
idol idol yeah i do i i would say that there are
a few people from which i i've learned um a huge
deal um at some point when when i thought my
question was always um who have been the the
most let's say influential relevant or important
people that have have lived this is a rather easy
question you study a bit you see them and so forth
but then the more interesting question is who are
those people uh today uh that that most people
don't don't really see that they're not yet the
most uh famous people but they're really really
good in what they're doing if you can discover
them you can find um the most relevant things in
different subjects at some point um i i believe it
was 2012 or something like that i thought that i i
at that point i discovered musk i discovered feel
and discovered paul graham um essentially devoured
everything they they wrote or thought about
and and so forth and was extremely fascinated
by what each of these individuals have
achieved and how they saw the world because at
the fundamental level there was a new way of
seeing the world each of them had um this view
on let's say program was was the grand master
in terms of startups that there was no one like
him peter thiel was was a really idiosyncratic
thinker in terms of technology startups and the
future and then musk like he's crazy of course uh
especially these days but there's basically no one
like him in terms of um achieving uh what what he
sets out to so these are a few really cool people
that that i've learned a tremendous amount from
elon musk is an interesting one because so i share
the same sentiment towards him um i think one man
going head to head with nasa gosh that sounds
like the beginning of like a movie title doesn't
it one man goes head to head so i think it's
unbelievable um and a lot of people hate what
he's done recently with regards to bitcoin
and and all that stuff and i understand that
um but i still don't think you can knock him for
what he's achieved i mean it's just insane um sure
sure no he he does have some things to learn uh
in terms of crypto and blockchain um i i suspect
uh that he has a grand plan for for this part
as well yeah there have been some cool threads
um but uh yeah i would not throw everything he's
done in the in the trash just because uh some
things seems uh seems crazy um it will be tricky
for him um of course like if he continues this um
at some point he it will it could backfire so uh i
guess yeah he is testing the limits at this point
uh i i would not want to to be uh yeah in that
position where uh everything is on the line
because i i tweet two three things and then things
start burning up oh yeah absolutely i think he has
a bigger plan um and we're yet to see what comes
of it um but of course back to you guys um so
launch pad i'm getting i'm getting when launch pad
that's what's coming through here on the questions
again we have some uh projects there uh we pushed
a lot um they're tremendously valuable we're super
super excited about them there have been some some
legal um discussions again uh legal seems to be
this thread that uh keems keeps reappearing in in
some of the things uh but we are now uh very very
close to having some updates on that front as well
um on those legal issues can you tell us anything
else um i know somebody was wondering what are the
legal issues that you have when it comes to the us
no so it's not legal issues it's just that
we're trying to approach things proactively
to make sure that we're bulletproof that
whenever there's a discussion we have
10 steps ahead make the plan can provide the the
details and at this point the the legal part uh
with respect to launch but projects is just trying
to help them prepare to to be ready and uh when
they move forward to to have things ready so that
um they're they've done their homework and and so
forth so someone's asking is this a paid interview
so i do want to just make this really clear this
isn't paid this isn't sponsored um i actually just
reached out to ben because um i was interested in
errands and i wanted to just learn more about the
community so yeah this absolutely isn't paid um
everybody knows i'm always honest when something
is paid i'm powered by icon plus capital and my
little sponsors are there in the corner blocked
by luno so yeah this isn't this isn't sponsored
at all um so we're getting questions through about
marketing why haven't you guys started marketing
which actually basically proves that this
isn't paid because this isn't a marketing thing
whatsoever sure uh so the idea is that we're in
a very very special position at this point we
now have the tools to really build anything on top
of a blockchain um and we've prepared some of the
last elements that we really need for the projects
to not only come in and play with the technology
but have what they need to build it have what they
need to launch their tokens create their economies
build their communities and push things to the
next level and during the next period we'll have
a very very very significant push on this front
just to uh bring everyone that has been building
on elrond um help them get out there have
them uh make the progress and and um launch
their entire ecosystems uh this will be the the
most interesting theme that that will follow
and just going back to the the decks we're
getting some questions through i know you said
it's not about comparing but i guess there are
so many different options in this space now as
things start to grow and really expand
so what would you say the difference
is between um the maya decks and then
something like pancake swap or uni swap
sure uh i i would say that there are a few
elements that really count um and would
bring us to a point where if you take a look at
especially uni swap and and some of these other
options uh there have been a very very limited
number of users that have been able to access this
either due to the the large fees and problems
that we've seen or due to the complexity and
it's here that we want to make a huge leap forward
both that this becomes super inexpensive and that
you can focus on on testing some of these elements
getting new features out and and so forth but then
also ux wise enabling a super large amount of
users to uh be part of this and be part from day
one is something that none of this ecosystems had
and we're very very curious to actually see how
the elrond community adopts and plays with these
tools as they come out so i'm reading that there's
been some fun i personally don't know enough
about this so um i'm getting could you please ask
um the big wallets so hang on let's have a look
okay so coin bureau basically are putting out
some funds about big wallets and centralization
i actually did read about this um so apparently
the majority of the supply is centralized so
talk to us about that yeah no this is this is
actually just a simple matter uh we've basically
discussed and the entire community knows this
the top 10 wallets are basically exchange wallets
this is this is uh not only for elrond but on
every blockchain when you have binance when you
have all the other large exchanges you have large
wallets that are the the uh cold and hot wallets
of the exchanges since the community knows this
there's basically not too much to to discuss
around it uh we will do something um that's still
proactive and helps diffuse any type of steam on
on this level uh we'll try to add some cool labels
on the explorer that just gives you an idea this
is the binance wallet this is the bitfenix wallet
and and so forth and by doing so um we're trying
to both anticipate and proactively defuse um
any type of discussion related to this we
actually um i would say are are at the point where
there are very very few networks that are as
decentralized and then scalable as as lron we
have a very large number of nodes um more than 3
200 number of nodes that are active in the network
more than 45 staking providers um and
then all the all the metrics uh around
adoption are also very very uh interesting so i
i always appreciate the the ball when it's raised
and will will try to score some some
goals with that so uh not nothing to to uh
worry about it's it's just the normal elements
and um i guess there have actually been some
some comments from the community where
um someone clarifies what each of the uh
accounts is is doing who it belongs to and and
so forth yeah i have seen that in the comments um
so there we go um so no i think everybody really
appreciated it i'm just reading through now
everyone says that's great we're getting some
um we're getting some answers we couldn't get
anywhere else so that's great that's always the
goal um okay so just lastly then because we're
coming up to an hour 45 minutes um what's
the entire 10-year plan what can we expect
yeah so this is uh the one element where we
think very very deeply about in addition to the
immediate part and as i said uh we believe that
this is a multi-trillion dollar opportunity a
generational opportunity that is unprecedented and
i i don't think we've seen any opportunity that is
as large and as significant as this since the
invention of the internet and this will have
implications for for countries um in the of the
world for for uh banks for institutions funds and
and startups and so forth so um we actually coined
this term uh of uh the the era of autonomous
banking and we believe that this is what's
going to happen we're going to have a kind of
100 trillion opportunity where states are going to
adopt blockchain technology as a as a settlement
layer banks the the smartest ones will proactively
try to um race uh in a way where they adopt this
technology then um startups are going to build on
it and what elrond specifically is going to do is
going back to what i've mentioned right
at the beginning create the backbone for
this high bandwidth low latency global and
transparent digital economy then give anyone
anywhere easy access through the meyer wallet by
connecting these two elements you you first have
internet like performance for the blockchain
so almost instant super inexpensive and global
and then by interacting with all this technology
in a wallet apple like with apple like experience
um you you basically are in a different
world you at that point you can see how
you can make all the payments just from one
wallet um can have new uh use cases for artists
where it's nfps and stuff like that
um but you you also have essentially a
fundamentally yeah significantly improved economy
it's like right now your the entire economy is
working uh with a very very slow feedback
loop so from you you have to wait 24 hours
until you make some transfers and they settle
and and so forth imagine what it would mean
to have this instant settlement layer for the
global economy um at that point you're you're
at a different level ben i want to thank you so
much it's been so brilliant um i think you know
just so everybody knows none of the questions that
we asked um initially were were given so i think
it's really brilliant just to be able to you know
address concerns and worries and fud and whatever
it is just on the spot i think it really puts
faith into the community so it's really important
um so yeah i want to thank you so much for joining
it's been absolutely great ben um really great to
be here i i think um it's probably the best time
to be alive uh we're super focused on the super
focus on the next steps and uh just focus on
making progress forward so thank you very much
yeah absolute pleasure and guys and please don't
forget to hit the subscribe button on my youtube
channel um i'm always going to be talking to um
really brilliant guests in the community um and
just spreading as much education awareness
and adoption as possible um because yeah
like ben says it's such a brilliant time to
be alive right now and we're so lucky to be
um right at the beginning of all of this because
i think it's just going to be bigger than then
we know so there you go um ben thank you so much
thank you everybody for watching um for tuning in
and please don't forget to subscribe so you never
miss a guest we will see you all next week bye bye